EG and Carroll the former magazine
columnist who claims Donald Trump raped
her she will return to the witness stand
this morning in her lawsuit against the
former president Carroll told jurors
just yesterday she was quote frightened
of Donald Trump meanwhile the former
president says the alleged assault
decades ago never happened in fact he's
never met her he claims Elaine quijano
has more of Carol's testimony and we
should note some of the details are
disturbing
Eugene Carroll waded through reporters
as she arrived at the Lower Manhattan
Courthouse Wednesday inside Carol took
the stand telling jurors I'm here
because Donald Trump raped me and when I
wrote about it he said it didn't happen
and shattered my reputation Carol who is
now 79 years old alleges former
president Trump attacked her in the
dressing room of an upscale New York
City Department Store in the 90s Carol
testified she has tried to pin down the
date of the alleged assault which she
believes took place in 1995 or 1996. at
times the testimony was graphic the
former L magazine writer and talk show
host told the jury he put his shoulder
against me and held me against the wall
Carol went on to testify Trump pulled
down my tights she testified she pushed
back and doesn't recall saying no but
quote may have e Gene Carroll says that
she had trauma throughout her life that
she felt as many sexual assault
survivors feel she felt like she was
soiled Goods she couldn't have a
romantic relationship she felt it was
her fault Trump has repeatedly denied
Carol's assault allegations in his
statement the communications director
for Trump's re-election campaign called
the civil suit a fake case and Witch
Hunt cross-examination is expected to
begin today what is the task for Donald
Trump's attorneys in this case Donald
Trump's attorneys Must Destroy this
story and show that it never took place
and that it is a story that was invented
by aging Carol
as we reported earlier the former
president does not plan to attend the
trial the judge gave a Stern warning to
Trump's attorneys telling them if their
client continues to post about this case
he could face potential liability Nate
we'll see if Trump or his lawyers listen
to the judge's warnings Elaine thank you